what up anime fans goes in here and time
for another review cuz you know why not
so today we're discussing orange
[Music]
Casa chain mojito mochi gotta be the guy
just kidding guys this isn't a cook yeah
spin-off this is talk about Ichigo taka
nose slice of life romance orange aka
the time-traveling letter writers
depressed almost boyfriend yes now if
you haven't watched I'll do a quick
spoiler free review before I get into
the good stuff in just in case you're a
dude thinking oh man slice of life
romances are so good
never fear there's time travel so when
your Bros asked you why you're watching
that slice of life romance that is
geared towards teenage girls you just
tell them I watch it for the time travel
breath it's so coud sted effect I rest
my case but in all seriousness it's not
really about the time travel time travel
has done well but it's not for Granite's
always stays in the background so don't
expect the Stein's get going into this
one onward to the story orange is a
manly tear inducing story about nah hole
a super shy small-town highschool girl
and her friends their lives forever
change when cocoon a transfer student
from Tokyo enters their lives what's
crazy about this is that na ho gets a
letter that was written in her own
handwriting that accurately predicts
cocoon whose arrival this letter is
actually from her future self at future
na ho wants present aho follow her
instructions carefully in order to save
kakadu from his own depression this
story is just as much about the rest of
the friends as it is about na ho in
kakadu the anime does a great job with
making us really care about all of these
characters personally I like SWAT and
hey Gaeta even more than kakadu so
that's it for the spoiler free synopsis
guys if you haven't watched it I do
recommend that you go watch it right now
and then come back here for the juicy
analysis alright so you've been warned
past this you're entering the spoilers
let's start with the music the soul of
every great feels trip now in my opinion
the music wasn't great at best I was
indifferent to it but at worst it
actually detracted from the viewing
experience it gets less bad as you go on
but during the first episode the song
called curry pan was off-putting and had
a place in my opinion it knocked me out
of the story instead of immersing me
into it
the music could also be one of the
reasons that I preferred the orange
manga over the anime just look at
Clannad through the music Julianna gives
your soul goosebumps but here I consider
myself lucky if the music wasn't in the
way this wasn't always the case but the
music definitely didn't Wow me and I
didn't feel like looking up these songs
after the anime like I did with animes
like AnoHana or Clannad and the
animation was sometimes beautiful most
of the times it was beautiful but
sometimes it looked like this and they
definitely should the bed throughout
episode 9 the inconsistency was
problematic because the great moments
made the bad moments look even worse by
contrast that like the music did
distract me from the story again the
main thing that a show should aim to do
is immerse you in its world but because
of its inconsistencies orange failed to
suspend my disbelief at times now this
was always the case especially during
the emotional parts of the anime and the
important parts at those times the
animation was on point possibly because
of the issues I dropped the series
before picking it up a month or two
later I did not feel the need to binge
watch like I felt when I watching some
of my favorite anime is like Clannad
Code Geass or death note however if you
can't push through some of the slower
parts the story and especially the last
episode is very satisfying I would say
that the best progress anime is the
story and it's characters I read the
manga and I loved it before watching the
anime so this didn't really come as a
surprise to me but you really start to
care about these characters na ho is
cripplingly shy at first but she pushes
herself to do things that even the most
confident
would have trouble doing like confessing
her feelings point-blank to Kakadu and
near the end she continuously tries to
instigate conversation and dates with
kakuzu
despite his consistent rejections some
may say Dena who is unrealistically shy
but I don't think so
she is continuously pushing her comfort
zone and going against her natural
disposition I'm sure that for her in the
beginning especially being assertive was
so unnatural that it felt like jumping
out of a plane it's unbelievably
difficult to go against your emotion but
she does it anyways and the process
transforms her into a completely
different person by the end this
transformation is symbolized in the way
she runs pass away in a senpai in the
last episode to give cocktail to smush
chocolates she is no longer willing to
be pushed around by when a senpai and
she no longer lets the little think
stopper or bother her she even leaves a
note for capital in his locker telling
him to wait not asking but straight-up
telling him to not go home she is
finally being assertive and she is no
longer willing to leave things to chance
to read this change though more
realistic and more subtle is just as
meaningful and impressive as Simone's
transformation in good and logon or
oppose transformation in Hajime no Ippo
through na ho orange flips the damsel in
distress trope on its head it is not ho
who must step up and save Kaka and she
totally does so I guess that would make
a kettle the damsel in distress I think
that orange handle gender conventions in
a great way it challenges gender
conventions but not in an absurd
over-the-top way like in frozen where
anna has to actually punch Hans in the
face at the end of it the challenging of
gender conventions is done right and
even when it's the guys turns it's
believable when we see sua or huh Geetha
or kakadu cry it's completely believable
and it completely makes sense that they
would in that context and then we have
cockatoo who has sold the press on
happy it's almost like he walks straight
out of a weekend song so yes kikuno can
be a crybaby but I mean he has real
reason to be his mom killed herself and
he finds himself to blame he thinks he
is responsible so I mean we can say
whatever we want
who wouldn't be depressed wreck if they
were in his shoes whether it's out of
sadness or happiness guys cry in the
anime and it's not seen as abnormal or
something to be frowned upon and that's
how it should be it's made clear in the
series that one reason kakadu died in
the future timeline is because he didn't
share his feelings but repress them it
is only through the subversion of
conventional gender roles that Cochrane
who can be saved this is true in the
anime and perhaps the author's
suggesting that it is no less true in
modern-day Japan with its high suicide
rates whether there are girls
courageously trying to save a boy's life
where a boy is crying because those
mother is dead this slice of life
doesn't feel forced it maintains a sense
of realism despite the fact that there
are time-traveling letters nothing about
this story feels cheap or phony and the
ending is all the better because it
refuses to be a fairy tale or they live
happily ever after
type of ending in the end all of the
game's efforts are rewarded and cocoon
who escapes that though barely you don't
know what will happen or cut Kahoot
trying to take his life again will not
hold Mary Kaku will she end up with Sula
like she said in the future timeline
that she will
what will sua do if the love of his life
ends up with another guy none of these
questions are answered but that's the
way it is in real life - for the time
being it's enough to know that the
future can be changed and that the game
will continue to do everything they can
to make sure kakadu is saved I'm happy
to know that no matter what happens in
the present time line in the future
timeline sua and na hole will end up
together and they'll have low baby Kaka
and that time I will be unaffected
because the multiple timeline theory
which is also used in steins gate it's
so crude
and how about sua sua story is perhaps
the most tragic in my opinion he can't
be with the girl he loves because that
would mean losing Kaku so either he has
to give up on cocoon or give up on his
own happy future being the selfless
lovable guy he is
he puts others before himself he loves
Navajo so much and yet he continues to
do everything in his power to set her in
Cocke throughout the episode where he
stays home because he knows that the
future him confesses his feelings for
Knothole on that christmas night is one
of the best examples of his
self-sacrificing ways he knows that he
can get the girl he loves it if he just
goes but he refuses to put his happiness
ahead of kaku's for this reason sua will
forever be remembered as one of the
greatest if not the greatest wingman in
anime history proms last Pahlavi's I do
want to talk about hi Geeta Geeta is
actually one of my favorite characters
and the whole anime it is amazing how
someone with so little screen time make
such a lasting impression his quirkiness
is [ __ ] hilarious I loved his back of
course of azu they're the real dream
couple I loved his awkwardness I laughed
my ass off when he insisted that
cockatoo take his glasses for good luck
when he randomly hug cockatoo and when
he broke out it was spike that was
probably one of my favorite moments in
anime history in conclusion the story is
a great one the anime does a good job of
being faithful in adapting the manga to
an anime but the inconsistencies I
talked about in the actual music the
pacing and in the animation as well
takes away from an otherwise solid story
with realistic and likable characters
although the anime I definitely
recommend it is definitely worth a watch
I do think that the manga is the better
way to experience this one so there it
is guys that was my orange review I hope
you guys liked this video let me know
what you think happened in the present
timeline and yeah if you like this be
sure to subscribe for more content and
until next time see you space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]